i am disgusted at how much you have
copied my husband from the hair to the
suit do you not have any value or
respect for originality
actually
you're dressed better than her husband
thank you now okay so look there's three
ladies in my hand jake there are three
ladies in your hand okay
she's blonde she's a brunette and she's
a redhead okay now i want you to pick up
the blonde
oh all right put it by the side of your
face
does that feel like the first time you
made love
no okay put her back put her back oh
okay pick up the brunette
uh all right put it there
does that feel like the first time you
did it
no no put her back too okay ooh now pick
up the redhead
redhead she's a redhead she's hot all
right does it do it for you
no not like the first time you had sex
put her back okay
okay now pick them all up
shake them up does that feel
[Applause]
[Music]
a new series of extras starts this week
uh congratulations on well i'm getting a
second series essentially but also
congratulations on already [ __ ] up
it's next week you [ __ ]
[Applause]
if we went to a movie together would we
sit next to each other would you want a
seat between us you know oh jesus cause
that's a tough i want to sit like nine
rows behind you and just tug on your
ponytail you savage that's what i would
do and england skipper andrew strauss
arrived in london proudly showing off
the little urn they'll spend four days
at home before flying out for the world
cup and belinda i just can't understand
how something so small can be so
impressive well mark you would know
about that
thank you very much
okay well uh which one of the other
players on the other team would you say
are you biggest competition
in this game
no one [ __ ]
see one of the problems i'm running into
with the show is the audiences are so
sweet and i appreciate that but
sometimes they don't understand that i i
like to get i like to get my balls my
balls broken
i think it's cool that you think that
you only have one problem on the show
so i'm letting that phone call in of
course yeah pillow talking that are you
ready for that you know pillow talk a
little bit of pillow talk a little bit
yeah that would be nice we could talk in
the daytime
yeah you're quite scintillating
scintillating yeah nice define that
what's that define it define what
scintillating you defend it you define
it you said it
english is not really my strongest
subject of course well i'm glad you said
it
oh yes
so primeval yeah it's sort of dinosaurs
and time portals
yes and and it's still more believable
than footballers wives
yes well
no
yes
[Music]
so you're standing next to ben yes who
you tried to kill in football as well
well he killed my husband can we get
that straight don't get picky what he
did
remind us how you tried to kill him i
poisoned you didn't i was it that well
you tried that and then you got a
shotgun and then i got a shotgun i
dressed up like cher and then i got a
shotgun and shot him
and you're still looking like cher
[Music]
well she looks good for her age unlike
some people
you're one of about five people that
have been invited around my house i'm a
very sort of private person apart from
like you know
workman and postman um and uh make me
feel special
kenny should give me back my hat your
hat is that yours it looks like a boy
hat no it's not it's mine it's yours i
think it looks like a country superstar
in it like kenny chesney he does she
doesn't except he should take his shirt
off he's going to it's coming up it's
coming up we promise we lose a camera at
that park before didn't somebody fall in
the water with camera was it there yeah
i don't even remember that oh it wasn't
a wave pool yeah the wave pool the waist
came in and then you looked real pretty
oh my what
it is
she talks so loud you can hear her
anyway
oh no we i think they wanted it off
just kidding just kidding
i'm just kidding jenny's feelings are
hurt where's she going now yes there oh
she's leaving she's going outside
well is traffic okay
a lot of people work really really hard
for their dreams but it's not meant for
everybody that's why you use auto-tune
and i don't
can you still dunk him when was the last
time you tried
can i still dunk are you stupid
[Applause]
you know i can still jump you know i can
still palm a basketball yeah i can still
do that oh man
oh man getting testy
yeah i am testing whoa dumb question man
oh man things that are you're supposed
to be afraid of there's a reason that
you're afraid of an anaconda you don't
want to get near it i wouldn't go well
then you're a little [ __ ] that's not my
fault
[Applause]
white people
calling the police on black people it's
an epidemic these days i mean
i'll read you some of the things uh
barbecuing while black not a good idea
apparently a little girl selling
lemonade
yeah the kid mowing the lawns was
another one he had no permit either a
lady trying to use a drugstore coupon
yeah how about napping while black
that's apparently that so your thoughts
oh
that is a specific group
these are specific people's actions
you know and i think that it wouldn't
matter what color the person is that
person is calling the cops for anything
yeah you know what you're crossing the
street and the light's not
it's not red
yeah why'd you cross before
oh you're from new york city so you walk
in the street regardless
okay now one way
but there seems to be more of it lately
yeah well it's being caught because of
the cameras that's true
so you think it was always happening
yeah yeah it's just now it's like the
even the police when we see the activity
now is because everything's on tape now
because cell phones
[Music]
i'd love to do something i think you'd
be good i think it'd be good you say
that but i when i try and write a joke i
get i get the opening bit i said that's
a funny idea madonna's got divorced and
then i think
yeah where's my writer you know i don't
well yeah i don't know
i heard you have a terrible theory and i
want you to say this so your theory on
boston is let's just wait till lebron's
old you don't want to be aggressive and
get players i didn't say that what did
you get misinformation what did you say
well why would you say i have a horrible
theory without checking with me first
it's like you already threw me under the
bus i get it you got a big desk i've
been dating the same woman for 31 years
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you
now
wait wait wait wait wait and she's
standing right here
what a beauty
i've only got a day to live i said what
do you want to do
[Laughter]
and then and then when that didn't
happen why is it yeah and then when that
couldn't happen make a wish foundation
i'd like to go on jimmy fallon please
and so you know that's not what you said
no no no i didn't yeah you want to do
something else and then i said anything
but jimmy
i think the media has done a terrible
job on this i think you yourself um you
know why you're a nice guy you know
you're full of sanctimony um you know
you become part of one of the parts of
the problem of the media you know you
come on here and you and you have a um
you know a monopoly on truth you know
you know exactly how things are supposed
to be done
um you know you are why one of the
reasons people can't stand the media
sorry you're cracking me up it's your
fault
it's
how so
what should i do differently michael
you know don't talk so much listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with it with with the media the media
doesn't get the story right the media
exists in its own bubble um that's true
i agree but you uh
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that that that i just had
to listen to of all of the people saying
the same old stuff also you're
incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean you're the flip
side of of of donald trump um you know
fake news and you say virtuous news
you know i they're they're not just
figure out what is real i mean yeah i'm
listening
well well figuring out yeah figuring out
what is real is not so is not so uh it's
not so easy and and you know most people
don't want to talk turn to brian stelter
to tell us what's real i'm sorry